this has become part of Sumaya bin
abdullah's daily routine
the government has switched off water
supply overnight in an attempt to reduce
consumption
I have a tank to save water and I put
buckets in the bathroom and kitchen look
what I do when I want to do the dishes I
fill bowls with water and use it but
what does someone who doesn't have a
tank do
it's part of tight restrictions
including a ban on the use of drinking
water for irrigating farmland or Gardens
that are expected to last until
September
for the past five years Tunisia has
battled a severe drought
the Ministry of Agriculture and Water
Resources says not one of the country's
30 dams is even a third full
authorities estimate water levels in
some dams have dropped 60 to 80 percent
the largest is only 17 percent full
currently we have reached the red line
or the danger line in terms of water
scarcity the dams are almost empty
some tunisians blame the government for
not raising awareness about the
importance of saving water
after shutting off the water for six to
seven hours a day information should
have been published about consumption
storage and the amount allowed to be
stored
the restrictions have prompted farming
unions to warn of catastrophically poor
harvest this year and are adding to the
already tense situation caused by poor
Public Services High inflation and a
weak economy
Al Jazeera
now Heatwave is baking